[Musique]
que feriez-vous si votre pays était
envahi par l'armée d'un pays voisin vous
cachez fuir résister ou rejoindre
l'armée et bien du jour au lendemain
c'est la question que des millions de
jeunes ukrainiens ont été obligés de se
poser et c'est une question qui va
changer évidemment le cours de leur vie
mais peut-être aussi le cours de
l'histoire alors à quoi ça ressemble
réellement de vivre dans un pays en
guerre pour répondre à cette question on
a choisi de se rendre sur place et c'est
ce que vous apprêtez à voir aujourd'hui
alors pour se rendre dans un pays en
guerre ce n'est pas si facile d'abord
pour être en règle et assuré il faut
récupérer un certain nombre d'éléments
déjà une carte de presse ukrainienne ce
qui nous permet de nous déplacer avec un
peu plus de liberté dans le pays en
évitant notamment les couvre-feu le soir
on a aussi du récupérer des trousses de
secours on sait jamais mais aussi des
gilets par balles qui sont en fait
obligatoire vis-à-vis de notre assurance
pour se rendre en Ukraine depuis de
France il y a pas de vol direct puisque
l'espace aérien est fermé dans le pays
depuis le premier jour de la guerre on a
donc pris un vol pour la Pologne et puis
on s'est rendu à la frontière avec
l'Ukraine et c'est là que tout a
réellement débuté
donc là on est à Rennes un des points
les plus à l'est de la Pologne et on
s'apprête à rentrer dans ce train-là ça
va être un peu votre maison sur les 14
prochaines heures puisque c'est ce
train-là de nuit qui nous amener jusqu'à
qui
[Musique]
très classique et très particulier
classique parce que à priori il y a tout
ce qu'il faut pour passer une bonne nuit
et passer les 14 prochaines heures
confortablement et en même temps on
comprend qu'on est très clairement en
zone de guerre déjà première chose on
vient de passer trois quatre heures de
contrôle aux frontières entre la Pologne
et l'Ukraine par ailleurs on le voit ici
toutes les vitres de ce train sont
recouvertes comme ça de scotch avec un
objectif très clair faire en sorte qu'en
cas d'explosion ou de souffle en fait
les vitres n'aillent pas sur nous tout
simplement et enfin dernière chose à
l'instant le responsable de la rame le
besoin de nous dire d'éteindre les
lumières pour faire en sorte que le
train ne soit pas visible et que ce ne
soit pas donc une cible pour les Russes
donc on va éteindre la lumière tout de
suite et essayer d'aller dormir
à notre arrivée en Ukraine on prend la
route pour la banlieue de quiz et sur le
trajet les destructions que l'on
aperçoit témoignent de combat très
violents
[Musique]
au début de la guerre sa femme et sa
fille ont fui directement vers la
Pologne lui n'est pas autorisé à quitter
l'Ukraine car comme tous les hommes de
18 à 60 ans il pourrait être un jour
mobilisé pour aller combattre
[Musique]
des contrôles comme celui-là on en a
vécu quasiment à chaque fois qu'on
prenait la voiture l'armée ukrainienne a
mis en place des checkpoints un petit
peu partout sur les routes du pays mais
particulièrement sur celle-ci car il y a
encore quelques mois les Russes sont
tentés de l'emprunter pour envahir qui
[Musique]
irpin en banlieue à tout juste 30
minutes de qui ici effectivement une
grande majorité des bâtiments a été
touché et surtout au moins 200 habitants
ont été tués dans les affrontements au
début de l'invasion le 24 février 2022
l'armée russe a en fait envahi l'Ukraine
par l'est le Sud mais aussi par le nord
et ce grâce à l'autorisation de la
Biélorussie alliée de Vladimir Poutine
l'objectif est alors le suivant
s'emparer le plus rapidement possible de
Kev et cette ville d'irpine est
justement la dernière étape avant la
capitale
ce quartier résidentiel a été au cœur de
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la bataille
d'irpine et par exemple sur cet immeuble
là c'est des dizaines de familles qui
habitaient avant on le voit les combats
ont été très intenses aujourd'hui il y a
plus que 5 familles qui vivent ici
[Musique]
et parmi les habitants encore présents
il y a volémyre 44 ans à notre arrivée
il vient rapidement à notre rencontre et
il me propose de monter sur le toit de
cette image
depuis le dernier étage de ce bâtiment
là on voit l'ampleur de cette bataille
d'erpine avec des traces d'obus
absolument partout sur ce bâtiment et
des impacts d'obus on en a par exemple
sur le bâtiment en face à droite ou
encore en face on le voit l'hôpital
d'irpine qui a été complètement bombardé
lors de cette bataille
[Musique]
à seulement 5 km d'erpines et toujours
dans la banlieue de cuve une deuxième
ville a été envahie et occupée par
l'armée russe il s'agit de bout de chat
[Musique]
si vous en avez déjà entendu parler
c'est parce que boucha est aujourd'hui
l'un des symboles de l'horreur de cette
guerre
[Musique]
et c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
décidé d'y aller sur place j'ai
rendez-vous avec mitia il a 22 ans et
pendant les premières semaines
d'occupation il est resté ici à
boutchaume
[Musique]
est-ce que tu étais le 24 février
le 26 mars 2022 après 20 mois
d'occupation la Russie annonce le
retraite ses soldats présents dans la
région autour de quiz officiellement
pour le gouvernement russe il s'agit
d'un changement de stratégie mais pour
l'Ukraine il s'agit d'une victoire celle
d'avoir repoussé l'armée russe
nous sommes alors à la fin du mois de
mars et le monde découvre ce que l'on
appelle aujourd'hui le massacre de
boucha près de 300 cordes civils sont à
l'heure découverts en pleine rue ou
alors enterré dans des fosses communes
les photos et les vidéos prises par les
habitants jouent alors un rôle
primordial et viennent alimenter
l'enquête sur ces crimes de guerre
sur ta chaîne Youtube on voit que tu as
filmé un certain nombre de choses que tu
as posté ensuite qu'est-ce qui t'a
poussé à filmer à documenter tout ça
passe par téléphone
ont été le terrain d'affrontement
pendant plusieurs semaines et même si
ces villes ont tout fait pour tenter
d'empêcher les soldats russes d'accéder
à quiz et bien la capitale n'a pas été
épargné pour autant parler de combat
[Musique]
elle n'a pas voulu fuir si bien que le
24 février quand les premières sirènes
retentissent et que l'invasion débute
elle se réfugie dans le sous-sol de cet
immeuble où habite sa mère
ça va
être grand ici
on était dans un moment on était
vraiment 10 avec avec deux enfants 10
personnes ici des personnes initiales
ici on avait la couverture où j'ai
essayé de dormir je devais
il y a le poussière et donc tous mes
vêtements étaient rouges comme ça beige
rouge
et très chaud ici on le sent directement
alors que nous ça fait que 30 secondes
qu'on est là mais toi ça tu as laissé
deux jours du coup ici
il n'y a pas d'air
donc on pouvait pas fermer
la porte de ce sol parce qu'on était on
avait pas que moi j'avais peur que c'est
le bâtiment
s'effon alors je pensais que je serais
personne bloquée ici c'est les portions
fermées
dans ce sous-sol avec une dizaine de
personnes avant de se réfugier dans le
métro et c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment là
que j'avais eu l'occasion de discuter
avec elle à distance à l'occasion d'un
live qu'on avait fait sur le sujet
c'est mon apprécie pour la nuit pour la
majorité de la majoritaires de la
journée comme elle des milliers
d'habitants de Quies ont donc vécu sous
terre pendant les premières semaines de
l'invasion russe dans ces stations de
métro aménagées pour servir d'abris
anti-monde alors la situation est
tristement différente depuis notre
retour à Paris et je vous en reparle
juste après mais quand on y était on a
été surpris de voir que les habitants ne
paniquaient pas quand les sirènes
d'alerte aux frappe aériennes
retentissaient dans la ville comme si à
qui la vie était presque revenue à la
normale les habitants se promènent dans
la rue les magasins et les restaurants
ouverts et même les spectacles ont
repris
[Musique]
Anna et humoriste et le 24 février elle
devait se produire à carquif une ville
située à l'est de l'Ukraine
au début du mois d'avril l'armée russe
qui donc les régions du nord de
l'Ukraine les villes dévastées alors un
nouveau chapitre celui de la
reconstruction
nous sommes dans le petit village de
kolitivka à 140 km de keeves tout au
nord de l'Ukraine
[Musique]
cette région a été occupée par l'armée
russe pendant un mois et elle a
notamment été lourdement bombardée par
des obus comme celui-ci des obus envoyé
depuis des lance-roquettes que l'on
appelle des grades une centaine de
jeunes bénévoles est arrivée ce week-end
à collectif k tous sont membres de
l'organisation repair together et leur
objectif c'est d'aller réparer ces
maisons dévastées par la guerre en
Ukraine ola y participent pour la
première fois
le village de collectif K a été libéré
par l'armée ukrainienne au tout début du
mois d'avril après 5 semaines
d'affrontement ou de nombreuses
habitations ont été détruites c'est le
cas de la maison de Katrina
où est-ce que vous étiez quand c'est
quand c'est arrivé
quel regard est-ce que vous portez sur
cette guerre qui se déroule depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
si Katrina ne ressent aucune haine
envers les Russes aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas forcément le cas de tous les
Ukrainiens ils étaient en fait nombreux
à avoir des amis ou des proches vivants
en Russie mais aujourd'hui beaucoup ont
coupé les liens et ressentent une colère
grandissante
retour à bout de chat dans la banlieue
quand l'armée russe est arrivée ici
mithia c'est rapidement porté volontaire
pour défendre sa ville en rejoignant
donc la défense territoriale du pays qui
lutte aux côtés de l'armée
c'est forcément particulier d'avoir une
grenade et une arme comme ça dans sa
chambre quand on a une vingtaine
d'années tu pensais te retrouver dans
cette situation un jour
n'est-il qui vous crée
d'ailleurs
dans la vie de tous les jours mitia et
skater professionnel avant la guerre
donc il ne savait pas se servir d'une
arme mais aujourd'hui ils se sont prêts
à défendre sa ville
de mostella costume
[Musique]
est resté à bout de chat et bien des
millions de jeunes ukrainiens ont choisi
d'aller encore plus loin dans la volonté
de s'engager en allant combattre
directement sur le front de la guerre
d'ailleurs on était en contact avec
plusieurs de civilités sur le front à
l'est du pays on avait prévu de les
rencontrer sur place mais finalement
l'avancée des troupes à l'est les a
empêché de se libérer aujourd'hui mitia
peut à nouveau sortir de chez lui et
faire du skate
un geste simple qui lui était pourtant
impossible pendant l'occupation russe
a
qu'est-ce que tu ressens quand tu vois
c'est c'est bâtiments ces maisons qui
ont été touchées
[Musique]
vivre en paix c'est ce que souhaite tous
les Ukrainiens que nous avons rencontré
sur place
mitsa a donc repris le skate et Anna a
repris ses spectacles nous la retrouvons
donc à qui après deux heures de chaux
sur le fait de rire à propos de la
guerre est-ce que tu as l'impression que
ça accepté par les gens ici est-ce qu'il
y a des gens qui s'appelaient pas
comment est-ce que tu vois tu vois tout
ça merci
la journée est terminée les travaux pour
reconstruire la maison de Katrina
reprendre donc demain et le soir les
bénévoles se retrouvent tous ensemble
pour aller faire la fête
extérieur certains peuvent trouver ça
étonnants bizarres de faire la fête
comme ça dans cette période là et dans
ce genre de situation toi comment est-ce
que tu le tu le vois au contraire ça te
semble la positif
parce que même maintenant il y a des
fêtes il y a des rêves et tout ça mais
les gens ne sont pas que c'était quelque
chose de bon oui parce que parce que la
guerre
et les gens les légendes font la fête
mais ici vraiment donc on travaille donc
les changements travaillaient depuis son
pendant 16 heures peut-être et
maintenant il mange et uniquement il
de se reposer et de cette manière je
suis incroyable pour pour se sentir même
plus haut même plus mobilisé même plus
solidaire solidaire oui et demain il
retourne au travail donc je pense que
c'est que c'est tellement mérité c'est
[Musique]
quelques jours après notre reportage qui
va de nouveau été bombardé et depuis les
bombardements s'enchaînent depuis le 10
octobre plusieurs grandes villes sont
régulièrement ciblées par les attaques
russes entraînant des coupures d'eau et
d'électricité plongeant les Ukrainiens
dans le noir et sans chauffage parfois
pendant plusieurs jours et ce en plein
hiver et signe de l'incertitude et de la
peur dans laquelle la population est
plongée aujourd'hui à qui on avait
tourné des images dans le quartier de
shephtenko pour montrer à quel point la
vie semblait avoir repris quelques jours
après notre départ ce même quartier et
ses mêmes rues ont été bombardées et
détruites c'est peut-être finalement ce
qui résume le mieux le quotidien dans un
pays en guerre des vagues lueur d'espoir
dans une incertitude et dans une
angoisse permanente ce que vous avez vu
dans cette vidéo c'est la vie de trois
jeunes Ukrainiens hola Anna et mitza
chacun tente de vivre dans la guerre au
quotidien comme il le peut mais une
chose les réunies c'est cette volonté de
se battre pour la paix et je vais leur
laisser le mot de la fin
[Musique]
itions
de plus en plus d'être financières et
monétaire alors je pense que ce sera
vraiment bio mais on doit survivre cet
hiver et après bien sûr elles prennent à
gagner quoi
[Musique]